cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
this next story
from Newsweek Joe Biden commemorating 9
11 in Alaska
Sparks backlash isn't that where the
third plane crashed yeah the the
mysterious
the lion was on it that's how Joe Biden
died Joe Biden did not go to New York
for the 911 memorials the first it's the
first president present to skip it I
think what I don't know if this is true
I saw a tweet it said that uh or an
exposed I'm sorry said that um the
response was 22 years after Pearl Harbor
president stopped going to Hawaii
yeah okay so uh I take offense to this
um I also take offense to this and when
you read the stories of 9 11 and and
most of us have read them to a great
degree especially the people who are
watching because some people have read
too many stories about 9 11 and some
people have read a healthy amount to
better understand what happened how it
happened and there's a lot of wild
things out there I think most of us
we've read quite a bit and you learn
about the heroism
um my uh uh uh what's the what's the
word um
the what's the oh I I'm I can't think of
the word but uh shout out I'll just say
that to Jon Stewart for standing up for
the 9 11 First Responders who are not
getting these oh he did that a lot right
and and it's brilliant because the men
who rushed when when people were running
away
rightly so there were people who ran
towards knowing what they had to do
knowing that they could leave their
children behind to have no father no
mother no family but they had to save as
many people as they could
and Joe Biden wasn't even commemorating
9 11. it's unfair to say that he did
what was he doing where he stopped in
Alaska is a typical refueling port for
Air Force One what really happened in my
opinion he was traveling back from
Southeast Asia and stopped to refuel and
they were like well you might as well
say something and I was like oh okay
yeah sure yeah Kamala Harris went to New
York instead that's an embarrassment
she's an embarrassment yeah she's a
horror she should have absolutely no
place near the White House ever under
any circumstance and she typically
doesn't I mean the Joe Biden
Administration does not engage with
Kamala that much she's so unpopular she
was in charge of the Border we never
hear from her so to send her in his
stead is like saying that's how much we
don't care about this right but also
they try and get everyone to say the
Biden Harris Administration that's what
the press secretary says Biden Harris I
refuse to allow that that's because
we're going into an election year and
they're trying to be like no no we have
a woman of color on the ticket so we're
better it's just disgusting yes she is
absolutely horrifying I want to give a
shout out to spike Cohen for this tweet
which I read and it's very difficult to
read and I pulled up the Wikipedia page
for the man he wrote about Ray rascorla
and uh reading this story
brings me to tears and fills me with
rage at the same time that Joe Biden
doesn't care
then and there's arguments about like
well we had to give the speech in
Vietnam or whatever it's like you do not
schedule things that interrupt you
showing up to New York for 9 11 Memorial
whatever whatever your thoughts about
911 the people posting World Trade
Center 7 all day it was trending
regardless the people died that day thou
people died afterwards people were
sickly afterwards dogs died lives were
sacrificed and this guy uh Rick
Rick roscorla has one of the most
incredible
stories I've ever read
I'll give it a simple version
security guard work of the World Trade
Centers it's concerned about a terror
attack potentially hitting the Trade
Centers has an assessment done they find
that there is a huge risk in the
basement a few years later some dude
tries to blow up the Trade Center by
doing exactly what they were warned
about he gets mad he begins these drills
every three months saying evacuations
why is he worked for Morgan Stanley's
security and they they had they were the
largest occupants of the South Tower
when 9 11 happened the North Tower gets
hit he immediately goes to everyone says
we practice for this we're getting out
but on the pa the Port Authority said to
stay at your desks he calls his best
friend and says that sobs are telling us
to stay I'm getting my people out of
here
only I believe 13 of the 2700 employees
at Morgan Stanley died because this guy
had a plan he was he was preparing for
for the risks thought ahead and he had
other people's lives in his mind not his
own
so after they evacuated people when the
first plane hit they had 17 minutes
before the before the South Tower was
hit he got out almost every single
person and then he went back inside
and they never saw him again and he told
his wife on the phone that you know if
she never sees him again he loves her
and she gave him everything ever wanted
and you hear stories like that and it's
not the first story we've ever we've
ever heard
there's so many stories and I hear a
story like that and I hear a story about
all the First Responders that Jon
Stewart was defending and this is what
gets me so angry at the people who would
uh reject I I think the 911 First
Responders should have been given a
million dollars a year for the rest of
the year for the rest of their lives and
so many other people in this country
considering how much wealth we have
and you hear stories like this and you
hear stories of the dudes who rushed in
full speed never to be seen again
leaving behind families the people who
are victims who died in this the people
standing at the edge of the of the
molten steel and the burning building as
it sprays out the people who had to live
for decades with damaged lungs and
cancer and the least you can do Joe
Biden is show up literally the minimum
is just showing up I'm pissed man what
gets me one of the things that bothers
me the most is that those people that
went back into the building should be
alive because buildings like that are
not supposed to fall down from Office
fires and that's what they thought they
all thought it the firefighters knew
going in they knew their risk was
burning smoke chemicals there's
potential for explosions if there's gas
stored somewhere not the building would
would collapse on everybody they all
knew the buildings would stay up that's
why they went in they believed they
believe funny how knowledge can can
change like that well it's an amazing
it's amazing too how fragile
civilization is how can just you know
crumble everything you can believe about
it you can believe that the you know
steel i-beams are going to stay forever
but it's all just gonna crumble yeah and
it crumbles quickly
you know I feel like our civilization is
crumbling rather quickly at this point
we built it up so high
you know it was so big and now it's just
like crumbling when I see stories like
this though
um
I mean what an amazing an incredible man
to to do this to know to not worry about
what the authorities are saying to know
himself what's important and to go for
that you know so often now people just
believe what they're told and there's no
reason to believe what you're told you
think you have to think for yourself in
every single circumstance
um and it's just like clear the more
things that come up that it turns out we
can't trust what we are told and we've
there was so much we were told that we
believed you know well and we see so
many examples of people who are given
jobs to protect other people failing I
mean I think about the Uvalde school
shooting when the school resource
officer wasn't there and then this guy
is like I am the head of security and I
am going to take it so seriously
we need it we need him everywhere and
it's interesting because he wants to
read that uh read that quote I can read
it uh he I will get him out short
reading this but uh he called his wife
Susan and said stop crying uh I have I
have to get these people out safely uh
if something should happen to me I want
to know I've never been happier you made
my life and I think that's so crazy that
like
this man was on the phone with his wife
it would have been so easy to be like I
got a bunch of people out I'm gonna run
up the street and he said like I am
going on my way home yeah I mean how
much would you think he wanted to be
with his wife in those last moments
right and even this is like he's Welsh
and I find this like to be very like UK
to me this idea that he's his wife is on
the phone she knows what's about to
happen she knows it's a risk and his
response is stop crying like we have a
job to do and we're gonna do it and
think about our current generation
think about the people we have today at
Uvaldi
man there was a post also from Ryan
gudurski talking about his uncle yeah
that was really powerful which was
really powerful his Uncle Pete who was
going in he thought his niece was in the
building and he kept going in to try and
get her out and and it turned out she
wasn't even it turns out she wasn't even
there but he kept going in and finding
somebody else and bringing them out and
then he'd go back in and he'd find
somebody else and bring that and he just
kept going back in to bring people out
and I remember that I remember that day
uh
because I mean I was in Philadelphia I
wasn't even in New York and it was your
birthday and it was my birthday but um
you know New York is always New York is
where my grandparents were born my
mother was born in New York uh
eventually my son was born in New York
but like
um I remember watching Rudy Giuliani
on TV because what happened was everyone
wanted news out of New York so all the
channels in Jersey and Philadelphia just
tuned into like the New York local
news like New York won right so we were
all just watching New York one and Rudy
Giuliani like
um came on and he started talking about
it and what was going down and he
started he started talking about how
alternate side of the street parking
would be suspended
so for those of you who are not you know
super familiar with parking in New York
they clean the streets and so every
couple days you got to move your car to
the other side of the street so they can
lean the street and Giuliani started
talking about alternate side of the
street parking would be suspended and I
I was like super emotional feeling I was
like New York is still New York
Rudy giuliani's in charge
he's you know he's gonna
he's Gonna Save the city again you know
and he did uh in a lot of ways
um but yeah the the people who did that
and later talking to my boss I worked
for this architecture company and my
boss was telling me his kids went to
school downtown and he lived in Brooklyn
and he walked a
he walked across the bridge everyone's
like running across the bridge trying to
get to Brooklyn everyone's like fleeing
downtown and he's walking the other way
to go get it to like go find his kids
and his kids his kids were okay and he
found them
um another person I know uh just was
like ended up writing a one-man show
called walk North and he had been
downtown and he just started like
walking North and like you know
everybody he ran into people just being
like do you guys does anyone need a
bathroom you could come to my apartment
does anyone need water like what does
anybody need you know my buddy was
walking North that morning after the
plane set similar situation to get
Uptown and then there's people were
screaming that there was another plane
coming and they all just thought that it
was no one knew what was happening
attack from all England they would
scream panicked and run into buildings
and hide and stuff like that no other
plans ever came after the second plane
hit everything changed when the first
plane hit it was was this a was this an
accident right that's what I thought
first yeah something like wow what could
have happened the low visibility who
knows and then the second plane hit and
it was clear and the stories I heard
from some people which is similar to
what you were saying no the day was not
over I mean World Trade Center 7
collapsed at what 5 p.m that day
something like that something like that
so I mean if if you're in New York and
after you know it's 10 a.m and this all
this is going down and then later on in
the day all of a sudden another building
just collapses
shattering in the middle and just
falling straight down without even being
hit by a plane who knows any building
could have just fallen down that was the
like you said earlier how fragile things
are in life and things and I I believe
that but I also believe that steel
skyscrapers are not fragile and that yes
life is fragile but life can also be
destroyed by outside forces if you're
not paying attention and just like the
United States was taking over in 1913 by
the this Federal reservist corporate
fascist system I feel like our our
buildings were blown up dude World Trade
Center seven does not just fall down on
its own unless its structures are blown
out who blew out the supports who why
didn't World Trade Center one two fall
in your free fall hoop left the supports
well the city also changed the way that
buildings were inspected so my
grandfather was in engineer and he would
like inspect buildings and the way that
he used to inspect buildings would he
would go up inside buildings and he
would check it out he would look at
everything he would you know see
everything he could possibly see he
would go up into all the different nooks
and crannies of the buildings and figure
out what was going on with it and the
city changed the rules of how you
inspect buildings so that no longer did
you have to go up into the building but
you could just stand in a building
somewhere else with a telescope and look
at the building from there
and look at it that way and my
grandfather was just like this is
ridiculous this is not how we fix
buildings and he was going up in
buildings being like I can see from here
that gargoyle is going to fall off of
you know whatever he was like going up
into the Chrysler Building and all this
stuff looking at it from all the angles
being like this is how you got to fix
your building your building is in danger
and but they changed the way that they
looked at the buildings they changed the
inspection methods and they made it they
made it worse they made it substantially
worse when do they do that I don't
remember exactly I knew you were gonna
ask me and I decided to tell you the
anecdote about my grandfather anyway
sweetheart but I know that um they did
change it and they changed it
substantially long enough ago I think
there's a a simple truth
the government did not tell you the
truth about what happened on 911 and I
don't care what the media writes about
me their morons if you think the United
States government being attacked or
whatever you think happened is going
let's let's hop into the assumption
that that everything about they said is
true that would mean that the US
government revealed to the world quite
literally how the Pentagon got attacked
that's crazy I'm not gonna do it they'll
tell you what they can tell you but
there's a thing called classified and
top secret and if you think that after
we got attacked on 9 11 the government
was like here's all of the secrets about
what happened oh come on so you know
it's funny when Vivek ramaswamy says
we're learning now about you know the
Saudi involvement or whatever and they
try to make them look like a conspiracy
theorist you really think that the
government just like Declassified
literally everything no there's there's
probably a bunch of documents that even
Trump knows and he was like oh wow
didn't know that happened but they're
not gonna tell you I remember at the
time so I remember at the time
um because after after 9 11 the rents
went down in New York and I was like oh
as soon as I get a job in New York I'm
moving to New York which is what I did
um but I remember when then it was the
Patriot Act which is of course one of
the most egregious violations of
American civil liberties in the history
of a country and it's still in effect
you know it's basically warrantless
surveillance of Americans uh what they
did in reaction to a global you know a
threat from outside of the country is
they decided to surveil Americans more
you know and now we have the doj that
says the biggest threat in the United
States is domestic terrorism
um that's crazy it's crazy and it
started with the Patriot Act and I
remember my theater group we started
doing protest pieces about the Patriot
Act
um that were like uh you know wiretapped
phone conversations from the Oval Office
like making fun of George Bush because
of course we hated him and then
and then it was March 2003
George Bush founded the Department of
Homeland Security which now has like
some 240 000 employees it's a huge
Department they're dismantling the
border with their huge department but he
launched that on March 1st 20 2003 and
then March 19th was the invasion of Iraq
and I remember like being like we're
invading we're invading a rock and this
was Saudi like we're invading Iran what
are we doing why is this even happening
then we go into Afghanistan which again
any student of History can tell you it's
a really bad idea to go try and fight a
war in Afghanistan that never works out
for anybody like that just never works
out why are we doing that and then Obama
was like oh I want to be president I'm
going to put more money into Afghanistan
and I was like well I can't vote for you
you're a warmongering crazy person like
we obviously can't do this and we just
kept going right down this road we
learned absolutely nothing unless that
was the plan all along was to create a
you know domestic surveillance state
where we just fund Wars to line the
pockets of presidents probably yeah I
think that was good American like free
speech and stuff it's okay but if you're
a rich corporatist it doesn't really
matter like you don't have free speech
in your corporation you run the show
right so someone pisses you off they're
gone and I don't think this idea of like
you can say whatever you want is even
like jives with his global banking uh I
don't know who who blew up those
buildings who who lined explosives that
blew the supports out on one and two
um
I I don't know I and to hear that there
were Saudis involved but that wasn't in
the mainstream is freakish uh
uh how how deep do you want to go
there's less well our Nano's thermite in
the dust well let's let's go crazy on
the members only show we'll go
absolutely just off the rails as far as
we can go but I want to I want to talk I
want to keep it a bit more uh topical
because we have the story from the post
millennial
Biden said he was at Ground Zero on the
day after 9 11. Congressional records
show he was on the senate floor uh I
utterly despise this man in he is the
worst he is so awful it's amazing how
bad and awful he is no no like he's a
liar he's committed bribery okay here's
the here's the here's the post here
here's the quote Ground Zero New York I
remember standing there the next day and
looking at the building I felt like I
was looking at the gates of hell it
would look so devastating here's him on
the senate floor on 9 12 at 1 45 PM now
let's play a game do you think it's
lying or do you think it's dementia do
you think he doesn't know when he's
trying to fabric a little bit a little
bit of both yeah whatever it's not crazy
sure nature versus nurture well it's
both you know do you think he's just
surrounded by people who are like yeah
tell that story sounds good man no back
in the day when he was young when there
was no internet and you couldn't pull up
the videos he could say anything did he
go there within like three weeks after
there was a senate delegation on
September 20th so he was like the next
day in his mind
I said the next day it was the next week
it's the same thing it was the next two
weeks yeah I don't know I don't know if
he was part of that thing then dementia
makes more sense well and also it's more
interesting if he's been lying his
entire career which we of course we know
he has dementia have both Clips in it
can you just scroll down both clips just
the one what the hell there's a link you
see you see Lady when we're using the
post millennial and we we give a shout
out to you uh but here's what's
interesting is that you know we just had
the other day Kamala Harris saying she's
ready to take over
and then but why would she need to tell
us that but then she's the one at the
911 memorial in Joe Biden ain't here
yeah why because maybe he can't stay
awake long enough
well he did say I couldn't meet with the
Chinese president because I have to go
to bed or something like that they were
like talking about he avoided the
question by like joking lose mainstream
terms there for and Gavin Newsom said
he's not gonna run because Kamala Harris
is next in line but that doesn't mean
anything right like he he says that now
and everyone's like see look he's
respecting the office but then you know
Kamala Harris he would run if he could
do it fast food restaurant and then
quits who knows she gets a job in
Academia where everyone who burns out in
politics goes uh no we I mean we talked
about possibility I think what's crazy
about the The Joe Biden Ground Zero
thing is first off open lie that anyone
could fact check also when Trump has
told a story about you know watching the
towers fly in like the planes fly into
the towers from his apartment and I
pulled it today the Washington Post had
this big fact-checking ball he said he
told the story here and then he said he
used a telescope and then he did
whatever like but no one is going to
issue a correction other than you know
respectful people at the post-millennial
right what is this that everyone can
pretend like Joe Biden is just saying
the truth all the time but anything
Trump does they are willing to tear down
and it's right there on C-Span there's a
photo of trump on the ground afterwards
during like recovery efforts and then
there's a fact check where it's like he
did not go down to 911 to and I was like
he's literally there they use
technicalities to be like this is what
they always do is they did Donald Trump
go down to uh to to the World Trade
Center a wreckage to help recover
on Sunday
2015. it was Monday you're right no
false Monday at four it was actually
Sunday at 3 17 right it was Tuesday it
was Tuesday right did you see the video
of him being like who set the bombs
there were bombs that went off who said
Trump said that yeah he went and and in
20. like the day the day after like he's
down at the at the wreck he's like I've
got 100 guys in there working right now
I'm headed in to give him moral support
I want to know and that's different
clips of him being like there were bombs
there were firemen were like bombs went
off boom boom boom boom boom and then
the building just comes down Trump knew
he was there he's like what these steel
skyscrapers do not just fall out of
office well we'll talk about that in the
members you sure will no nuts I think
one of the craziest things and I think
Trump is representational this is when
he talks about 911 he talks about it
with well you know a gravity that we're
obviously not seeing from Joe Biden
right I mean Joe Biden Trump's Hometown
it's Trump Hometown he feels it really
deeply and I think it it reminds me of
because I grew up in Connecticut so you
know we did like everyone got bust home
from school it was a big deal I I was
very young so like I don't have all the
clearest memories of it but you know
four years especially growing up in this
region you know people who have stories
are like oh yeah my my Dad was supposed
to have a meeting there that day and
then he didn't or like my mom did this
that and the other and you know whatever
you know people are affected by it the
one that I think of the most is uh
someone I knew had a a son who was in
high school at the time they could see
the buildings coming down from his high
school and he was staying with a
classmate and the family friend's son is
uh Catholic so he said a prayer and then
he crossed himself and his friend was
like went home to his dad and said you
know I wish we had something like that
because I I in moments of these complete
Terror how does anyone respond and I
wish I had a way to just like express
how I was feeling and I find this really
interesting because rather than
acknowledge the gravity of the situation
and the fact that so many people had
this moment where they thought are we
going to be okay we collectively to then
decide like Trump is wrong because he
didn't go down when we said he did
meanwhile it's okay for Biden to say
well after 20 years I've decided it's
not worth remembering this I mean this
impacted people so profoundly that maybe
he should have just been honest I've
been like but yeah we had to refuel on
the way home from Asia I couldn't make
it but even then it seems crazy where
the generation you're targeting with
votes don't remember so it's not just
people who are born
in 2001 or after it's the people who
were born in 1997. who don't remember I
remember I mean I remember after my
mother was a Securities lawyer she's
retired but I remember after after this
day I saw her a little while later
cleaning out her Rolodex we used to have
this thing it was called a Rolodex you'd
put phone numbers in it on paper yeah
and it would be a hole in it and it
would be like a Loosely find her if
anyone knows what that is anyway she was
literally tearing names out of her
Rolodex
um people who had not only died but
anyone who had an office in the Trade
Center because that was also useless
that was their work number and work
address yeah wow
um and that was a that was a very
chilling moment for me and I was like
what are you doing she's like none of
these people work here anymore and some
of them are not alive and I was like
okay wow which is great the fact that
she could spend an afternoon doing that
wasn't it like uh Seth MacFarlane was
supposed to be on one of the planes oh I
think it I think that's the story uh I
don't know for sure happened yeah
you got a call from mayor Willie Brown
or something no I'm kidding
now Willie Brown apparently said he got
a phone call or something like that well
I I will say well we're gonna we're
gonna go ham on the members only we're
gonna go ham right we can because we got
a bunch of other news stories yeah it
says he missed by about 10 minutes
missed flight 11. he and Mark Wahlberg
were supposed that's what I was thinking
of there are all crazy there are
children who are growing up having never
been without TSA like yeah you know I
never never traveled before that like I
I that's crazy it doesn't make any sense
but at the same time 20 years is a
really long time there are kids born
after 9 11 who only know about life
under the patriarch with these these
intensities but I I never flew
before TSA you know when I was a kid uh
my parents my dad lived in Boston and I
grew up and I lived with my dad and my
mom lived in New York she lived um 165
with 66th Street and I used to fly back
and forth on the Eastern Airlines
shuttle Eastern also doesn't exist I am
so old you guys anyway I used to fly
back and forth between my parents and my
dad would like at Logan Airport he would
walk me to the gate and like see me off
and sometimes he would walk me onto the
plane and in movies the people are
waiting outside the gate like yay and I
used to have it and my mom would be like
right outside the right outside the
plane when I got off the plane she would
be right there and then there was this
weird time when like all the
unaccompanied minors got lost by the
Airlines and that was really weird
um for hours no one knew where and I
remember being like in a big room at an
airport with like hundreds of kids yeah
just like all of us sitting there for
tape I worked at O'Hare when I was 18
until I was 20. and so this is just four
years you know after 9 11. and I talked
to the guys who worked there who had
been there when it happened and they
said this is what I was told by a
handful of the guys that after it
happened
within you know 15 or so minutes there
were guys in suits with rifles standing
on the tarmac and then and that's nuts
yeah they were alive how they get there
so weapons well I mean there's there's
they're there serious law enforcement at
airports so I'm sure when they were like
we have a terror thing attack happening
the airport send out the the dudes to go
on lockdown and they're like they're men
with guns standing outside in the tarmac
looking around keeping everyone away
trying to figure out what's going on I
was in New York like just a like a week
later or so after 9 11 and there were
guys just standing on street corners
like army guys in Greenwich Village with
like huge guns and I remember just being
terrified like there's crazy army guys
standing here with guns all down in the
West Village like that's nuts I worked
there I I moved to New York September
5th six days later they came down the
buildings and then I started working
messed up Ground Zero like October or
13th or something a month later I
started working there it was all
militarized it was like like devastating
Nation kind of windows were blown out
and the buildings all nearby and like at
the time I was like I guess that's what
happens when buildings fall down I
didn't consider the projectile force
from the bombs going off I'm blowing out
the supports apparently that's why
wake up went flying out the side
according to the official report the
pressure from the pancaking effect
forcing air out the windows they got you
the official report nist National
Institute of science do you remember
this does not explain all the all the
the portable phones that they just set
up and like parked you remember that I
never used one no but they were there
I don't I don't know if the nist report
discussed seven retro 10 or seven did it
um yeah I think it did but I haven't
read much about that I don't know if the
nist report does they talk about how the
building seven pancaked and then no no
no no no no no no no they give some half
um no no you're talking about building
one and two I'm saying World Trade
Center seven was where the the propane
tanks exploded after fires got out of
control causing it to to crump his
propane that blew up the entire
something like something that's I'm
saying I'm saying the official official
official statement on World Trade Center
seven I believe is debris from Trade
Centers one and two caused fires in
World Trade Center seven which burned
out of control so funny because of the
chaos and limited resource there's no
firefighters resulting in like you know
like stored gas tanks bursting or
something like that which then started
weakening various portions of the
building causing it to just crumple and
then fall yeah there's a digital
um simulation of the of the building
crumpling and they only show the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology only show like a portion of
the Fall you know but then it doesn't
really explain why it fell on your free
fall we're gonna we're going to
get in all that at the members only so
go to timcast.com click join us become a
member and then in one hour we're gonna
have a very interesting conversation I
imagine about
um
unofficial uh beliefs thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time